consider the people who are doing this
nancy pelosi nancy pelosi
and and all the rest of them by the way
maxine think about maxine waters who
explicitly called for violence against
republicans think about
hillary clinton who said you can't be
civil with republicans think about
all of these other people but nancy
pelosi speaker of the house
she decides that the people's business
it's very very important
that house democrats pass a resolution
such that the house rules will no longer
include
gendered language all the troubles we
face right now
the draconian lockdowns people losing
their livelihoods threats from abroad
rising china all of these issues
nancy pelosi says very very important we
pass this resolution such that the house
rules
will not include gendered language
listen to the arguments she makes
for that resolution this is not
theoretical and this is not motivated by
partisanship
i stand before you today as an officer
of the constitution
a speaker of the house of
representatives i stand before you as a
wife
a mother a grandmother a daughter
hold on she wants to pass
a resolution getting rid of gendered
language in the house rules
and to defend that she says i stand
before you as a wife
a mother a grandmother
a would you call that gendered language
i think i would that sounds like the
most gendered language
you can use which is hilarious and it
shows their
sort of frivolity and ignorance but it
also shows something a little bit deeper
about all these
moral claims that they're making namely
they will not hold themselves to those
standards they will hold you to those
standards they won't hold themselves to
those standards
president trump says go peacefully
protest at the capitol
and then some violence occurs they say
off with his head basically
but they explicitly encourage violence
maxine waters right hillary clinton
don't be civil
chris cuomo comes out and says protests
don't need to be peaceful
they encourage the quote-unquote
peaceful protests that
seem inevitably to turn into these riots
they go on television they say
with buildings on fire this is a mostly
peaceful protest they bail out the
rioters
like kamala harris did and then they try
to impeach trump and some squishy
republicans still don't get it
those handful of people led by liz
cheney that we named
maybe they do get it maybe they're just
not on the right side if you enjoyed
that video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got
the absolute top content out there
[Music]
[Music]